lots of reaction from people here in
westminster but leaders uh further
afield as well the tishook the prime
minister and the republic of ireland um
mihor martin has issued a tribute in
which he said he wishes to express his
deepest condolences to the family
colleagues and friends of david trimble
he played a key role as leader of the
uup and was a long and distinguished
career in unionist politics and in the
politics of northern ireland all of us
in politics at the time witnessed his
crucial and courageous role in the
negotiations leading to the good friday
agreement and his leadership in building
support in his party and his community
for the agreement fittingly his
contribution was recognized
internationally and most notably by the
awarding of the nobel peace prize to
himself and john hume for their joint
efforts to find a peaceful solution to
the conflict um in northern ireland
we've also had um some reaction from sir
jeffrey donaldson who of course is the
current leader of the dup the democratic
democratic unionist party someone that's
been involved um quite heavily in the
ongoing process over the northern
ireland protocol
he has said that he's deeply saddened to
learn of david's passing and my thoughts
are foremost with daphne and their
children at this painful time throughout
some of the most difficult years of the
troubles david was a committed and
passionate advocate for the union at a
time when doing so placed a considerable
threat to his safety while our political
paths parted within the ulster unionist
party there can be no doubting his
bravery and determination in leadership
at that time he was a committed and
passionate unionist who always wanted
the best for northern ireland right
until recent days david continued to use
his political skill and intellect most
recently in his support of the united
kingdom's decision to leave the european
union and in opposition to the northern
ireland protocol as a nobel prize
laureate his words carried significant
weight and he helped raise awareness of
the threat the protocol posted northern
ireland particularly amongst the wider
uk audience of course lord trimble was
someone that was often cited by um those
that were
fighting against the northern ireland
protocol that part of the brexit deal
that essentially kept northern ireland
in closer alignment with the rest of the
eu david trimble was very vocal about
the impact that he felt that had on the
good friday
agreement so when there were points
being made from the other side
essentially saying that it was a
northern ireland protocol that was put
there to safeguard the good friday
agreement often those on the side of the
dup fighting against that would point to
lord trimble um and his words and the
pieces that he wrote to essentially um
back up their point so even though i
guess in a way out of front nine
politics in the limelight for quite a
while clearly the weight and the
gravitas that he brought with his
history and his political history
was still being referred to and used
right up until recent months um as well
um we've also had um reaction haven't we
from the from the british government
from um
from the northern ireland sector yeah
shiloh shvara the northern ireland
secretary appointed a couple of weeks
ago in the midst of all that turmoil
after boris johnson resigned he said the
loss of david trimble will be felt
deeply throughout northern ireland my
heart goes out to his family and friends
he'll be remembered for his unshaking
defense of peace and his leadership in
helping deliver the belfast
good friday agreement there's also been
a statement issued as well by jerry
adams he said david faced huge
challenges when he led the ulster
unionist party in the good friday
agreement negotiations and persuaded his
party to sign on for it it is to his
credit that he supported that agreement
i thank him for that in the years
immediately following the agreement i
met david many times our conversations
were not always easy but we made
progress we used to meet quite often on
our own and i got to know him well while
we had while we held fundamentally
different political opinions on the way
forward nonetheless i believe he was
committed to making the peace process
work david's contribution to the good
friday agreement and to the quarter
century of relative peace that followed
cannot be underestimated i want to
extend my sincerest condolences to
daphne trimble their daughters victoria
and sarah and their sons so
people from quite different i guess
political backgrounds very interesting
statement that wasn't it
a warm statement and we've also had
david cameron saying that this is
desperately sad news and that as an
architect of the good friday agreement
he took significant political risks but
in doing so helped bring the parties of
northern ireland together for the first
time to achieve a lasting peace